whereas to graph the inequality y is
less than three x plus five so if you
give us any x and let me label the axes
here so this is the x axis this is the y
axis so this is saying you give me an x
so let's say we take x is equal to 1
right there
3 times 1 plus 5. so 3 times x plus 5.
so 3 times 1 is 3 plus 5 is 8. so 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8. this is saying that y will be
less than 8. y will be less than 3 times
1 plus 5. so the y values that satisfy
this constraint for that x are going to
be all of these values down here let me
do it in a lighter color it will be all
of these values for x is equal to 1 it
will be all the values down here and it
would not include y is equal to 8 y has
to be less than 8. now if we kept doing
that we would essentially just graph the
line of y is equal to 3x plus 5 but we
wouldn't include it we would just
include everything below it just like we
did right here so we know how to graph
just y is equal to 3x plus 5. let me
write it over here so if i were to write
y
is equal to 3x plus 5 we'd say okay 3 is
the slope
slope
is equal to 3 and then 5 is the
y-intercept
now i could just graph the line but
because that won't be included in the
y's that satisfy this constraint i'm
going to graph it as a dotted line so
we'll start with the y-intercept of 5.
so 1 2 3 4 5 that's the y-intercept and
the slope is 3. so if you go over the 1
you go up
3. so let me do that in that darker
purple color
so it'll look like this
it will look like
that and this you would that point would
be on it that point would be on it if
you go back you're going to go down by
three
so that point will be on it that point
and that point and i'll just connect the
dots with a dotted line
so it will look
so that is that dotted line is the graph
of y is equal to 3x plus 5 but we're not
going to include it so that's why i made
it a dotted line because we want all of
the y's that are less than that so for
any x
so you pick an x let's say x is equal to
negative 1. if you evaluate 3x plus 5
for that x you'd get here but we only
care about the y's that are strictly
less than that so you don't include the
line it's everything below it so for any
x you pick it's going to be below that
line you go you take the x go up to that
line and everything below it so for all
of the x's it's going to be this entire
area
it's going to be this entire area let me
draw it a little bit neater than that
it's going to be this entire area that's
under the line i'll do it in this orange
it's a little easier to see
so this entire area under the line
is
y is less than y is less than three x
plus five